es por el espíritu republicano que dice
defender que el alcalde de cannes David
liznaga quién apoyaba el rey peca es
decidió dar su aval hace un look melón
asegura que debe poder competir
que los avales no comprometen a los
apoyos debemos cuidar la líder expresión
democrática
solo tiene 370 firmas a menos de 2
semanas de la fecha límite solo seis
candidatos tienen los 500 avales
necesarios tres de los principales
aspirantes Están particularmente
preocupados de los contentores de la
izquierda Cristian tobija con solo 86
firmas y de la extrema derecha erreximum
También tienen dificultades
es una situación democrática
a la isla de la reunión para dedicarse a
este cometido los llamados a reformar el
ha dejado de presentarse por falta de
vales